(audience applauding)
All right next up,
we have a story about some incredible young people
stepping up in their community.
CBS News reports that there is an EMT shortage
in America.
In rural areas,
35% of ambulance services are volunteer,
and 69% of those are understaffed.
And in a small town of Sackets Harbor, New York,
a group of teens has taken the initiative
to get certified as first responders
in order to fill out their local EMT force.
They're also students
attending high school full-time,
but they say putting in the extra hours
to help others in their toughest times
is worth it to them.
(Drew groans)
I know.
This is the stuff
I need to hear.
(audience applauding)
This is the stuff I need to hear about.
I need that belief system
that good things are taking place
and good people exist.
You have my deepest respect and admiration,
thank you so much
to those teenagers.
(audience applauding)
Yeah.
And I think--
(audience applauding)
You think about--
I think about
(audience applauding)
how they always say,
oh, these kids these days,
kids these days.
Yes.
Right?
And oh, what the future's gonna bring.
When I read this story,
it made me feel like if this is the future,
the next generation,
maybe because of kids like this,
we're gonna be okay.
I Agree, and as a parent,
I could only dream
if my children did something like this,
these parents, I hope you're very proud.
Yeah, you should be very proud.
We're proud of you
Your kids.
and your kids,
Well done.
(audience applauding)
All right,
(hands thudding)
(audience applauding)
Next up,
we have an interesting study from the UK.
Metro reports,
a survey found two thirds of adults
say that music in stores and restaurants,
we've all heard that,
well, can actually affect what you buy.
In terms of genre,
pop music was found to increase spending
on more extravagant clothes or sneakers,
and if classical music is playing at a restaurant,
31% of people said they might order a pricier entree.
I will tell you this,
I was at HomeGoods this past weekend
and they were playing like classical music,
and then I realized it was like a Bruno Mars bop,
then I was like,
oh, I was in the mood,
and I did buy three decorative throw pillows
I didn't need.
So, I think
(audience laughing)
there's something to this story.
I love that like classical music,
like induces a little like 1980s Grey Poupon commercial,
where you go a little fancier,
like all of a sudden you're like,
"I'll have the lamb."
Or, you know, whatever it is you order,
but I like that you shop and bop,
that kind of is super cute,
Totally.
and I totally get that.
I will say this,
I cannot eat to a lot of styles of music.
Music to me is like really sexy,
and when I'm eating,
I'm not thinking sexy thoughts,
I'm more like I want Billy Holiday
or like classical,
but I can't like,
"This is not."
(audience laughing)
This is like--
(bowl clinks)
I'm much more of like prone to the alley cats,
who are like,
(Drew mimics cat hissing)
Yeah.
I'm eating!
(Ross chuckles)
(audience applauding)
However, cooking,
I feel like,
bring on the music,
Yeah?
but when it comes to time to eat,
I can't--
Sex and food
(Drew chuckles)
don't go together for me.
(audience laughing)
I am not George Costanza
(Ross chuckles)
who wants to eat
a turkey sandwich
(Ross chuckles)
and do it,
if you know what I mean?
(both chuckling)
Although that's the best episode ever.
That's a great reference.
(Ross chuckles)
Anyway, we'll be right back.
(upbeat music)
(upbeat music fades)